une mesure coup de poing ces mots 2 ans
0 ming du bureau des affaires de hong
kong et de macao évoque l'autonomie en
kongaise le parlement chinois adopte à
la quasi-unanimité une réforme du
système électoral de la région autonome
celle-ci autoriserait pékin a
sélectionné les candidats aux élections
législatives à hong kong et lui
permettrait ainsi d'écarter les
candidats défavorable au gouvernement
central chinois
bon nombre d'entre eux avaient remporté
en grande partie l'élection des
conseillers de district en 2019 ces
dernières années le chaos dans la
société hongkongaise a montré qu'il y
avait des failles et des lacunes
manifestes dans le système électoral y
compris la méthode de sélection du chef
de l'exécutif et du conseil législatif
en particulier le manque de sécurité du
scrutin a permis aux éléments anti
chinois qui ont perturbé en content de
faire partie des organes politiques et
d'autres structures de gouvernance de la
région administrative spéciale de
l'étranger beaucoup dénoncent une
atteinte significative au statut semi
autonome de la région administrative
un principe garanti par la déclarations
sino britannique publiée lors de la
rétrocession du territoire en 1997
la décision prise aujourd'hui constitue
une nouvelle violation du principe un
pays deux systèmes
l'union européenne va envisager la
possibilité d'adopter des mesures
supplémentaires
ces actes prive les hong kong et d'avoir
leur mot à dire sur leur propre
gouvernance en limitant la participation
politique en réduisant la représentation
démocratique tout en étouffant le débat
politique
pékin rejette formellement les critiques
formulées par bruxelles et washington
qui appelle à des élections législatives
transparentes en septembre prochain
la chine qui assure ne vouloir faire
aucune concession face à ces puissances
qui selon elle vise à déstabiliser hong
kong en 2019
un premier projet de loi sur la sécurité
nationale avait secoué la région
autonome
celui ci autorise pékin au nom de la
sûreté à intervenir dans le système
juridique hong kong et un amendement qui
avait poussé de nombreux citoyens
descendent dans la rue